democratic presidential nominee joe
biden was visibly angry over the
president's reported remarks about
soldiers friday
and leveled one of his most forceful
attacks against mr trump
ed o'keefe has more an irate joe biden
called the president's reported comments
disgusting
and un-american if these statements are
true
the president should humbly apologize
to every gold star mother and father
and every blue star family that he's
denigrated and sold it
who the heck does he think he is
biden himself never served in uniform
but his late son beau
did my son volunteered
and joined the united states military as
the attorney general
and went to iraq for a year he wasn't a
sucker
the service men and women he served with
particularly those did not come home
were not
losers the former vice president
originally planned to focus friday just
on the economy
but said the president's remarks made
him the closest he's come to losing his
temper
on the campaign trail is there a lot of
people out there who are
supporting you or inclined to not vote
for the president who would say
why isn't joe biden angrier about all of
this
getting down in the gutter like the
president does
saying things that i'd be inclined if we
were behind a barn somewhere
it'd be a different thing but that's not
the job of a president
mail-in voting kicked off in the key
swing state of north carolina on friday
with a record 600 thousand absentee
ballots sent out
the president has consistently attacked
voting by mail and this past week he's
urged supporters who do vote by mail
to also go to the polls in person send
in your early ballot
and then go and make sure that ballot is
tabulated or counted
and if it's not counted vote how many
times
does this president have to suggest
things and say things
well you all don't just write he's a
fraud
and what could be an intriguing
encounter both biden and the president
are scheduled to attend a 9 11
commemoration ceremony on friday
in shanksville pennsylvania i asked the
former vice president whether he'd be
willing to share a stage with mr trump
he said he would because quote he is
still the president of the united states
for cbs this morning saturday at o'keefe
wilmington delaware